I remember my mom told stories and I
remember him she doesn't have to remind
me of them where I would like see a
movie and I'd like it and I used to play
with GI Joes all the time you know I had
a whole bunch of GI Joes those dolls and
I would always play movies basically I
would just kind of like do my version of
whatever I saw you know and then I would
like be acting out all the parts with
all the GI Joes and I would be like you
know kind of like directing these little
plays just for myself with the GI Joes
and the same thing is like you know I
would you know and I'd see some movie
because I saw all kinds of stuff not
just Herbie Goes On Monte Carlo but like
all kinds of like a
um you know my mom took me to see
caramel knowledge and the Wild Bunch and
all these kind of movies when I was a
kid
foreign
but it's like funny though because it's
like I would like you know I would act
them out like I saw in the movie so I'd
have like oh yeah dirty you know and
your mother you know be like dealing
with Quentin what's going on up there
you know it's not me Mom it's them I
chose that's just the dialogue from the
movie